the roads in afghanistan have become too
dangerous
even for the one hour drive from kabul
to logar
from the air the southeastern province
looks peaceful
but on the ground the devastation caused
by a powerful track bomb days ago
is a reminder of how volatile the area
is
the hospital is totally destroyed all
the employees are trying to clean the
place the broken glass and the rooms
the staff are trying to rebuild the
hospital from nothing
in just a few days because the
government is not helping us
a few meters away members of a peace
movement set up a tent
they are demanding a ceasefire and want
their voices heard
the guest house next to the tent where
dozens of high school students
were waiting to take their university
entrance exams
has been leveled the taliban has been
active in logar for years and the
government has blamed it
for this devastating car bomb attack but
the group
has yet to respond to the accusations
the logar governor says they have
evidence the taliban carried out the
attack
he believes despite the foreign troop
withdrawal the afghan defense forces can
continue to fight the group
and he says he's more concerned about
foreign fighters
that use the 14-kilometer border
separating logar from pakistan the
pressure comes on longer and from longer
than they
the taliban have foreign advisers like
pakistanis
like arabs like people from uzbekistan
from tajikistan the igor people
they are here they are giving them
trainings they
they are giving them they are making the
car bombs for them
the western world nato is saying okay
guys we finished the job successfully we
killed osama bin laden
and now we are going and they are
leaving behind
a war which fought for 20 years all
these people trained
in guerilla warfare bomb making
and lots of other things
they are leaving international
communities leaving afghanistan
to go into chaos
while the government says they keep
conducting operations against
what it calls terrorist groups near the
logar border
shopkeepers at the capitals bazaar are
trying to rebuild their shops
it will take them days to restart their
businesses
and money that no one will compensate
them for
security is deteriorating day by day we
cannot run our businesses
properly we're working in fear and it's
too difficult to have a shop here
i insist that we have a stable peace for
our country
and that peace is the one thing everyone
longs for
felio contra fourie al jazeera logar